On average, you produced just over
two kilograms of waste every day.
That may not sound like a whole lot,
but multiplied by every person on earth
and suddenly you've got 14.8 billion
kilograms of waste being
produced every 24 hours.
But what would happen if we
suddenly stopped recycling?
Would the world be quickly flooded with
garbage? Would we fire it into space?
This is what if, and here's what would
happen if everyone stopped recycling.
Nearly everything we buy has some
recyclable component, glass paper,
plastic metal,
and other materials.
The United States where cycles about
65 million tons of waste each year,
which is just 30% if it's 200 million
tons of yearly waste around the world.
Recycling is a massive industry.
Countries in Europe like Austria and
Germany recycle over 50% of their waste
every year.
Now,
what would happen if everyone in
the planet just decided to stop?
If the world stopped recycling,
every single scrap of waste
would end up in a landfill. Well,
most of it with a larger amount of trash,
it's inevitable that we'd get more in
places where it shouldn't be. At first,
you probably wouldn't notice anything.
In a best case scenario,
most landfills around the world
expect to last 30 to 50 years.
One of America's largest landfills
began accepting garbage back in 1957 and
finally stopped in 2013
that's 56 years of trash.
It may take a couple of years,
even decades before garbage
starts piling up everywhere.
So what happens when those
landfills finally fill up?
When landfills become too full
to take on any more garbage,
they're covered with clay
and soil to form large hills.
You might think the job is done at that
point that you'll never need to think
about that stinky garbage ever again.
But sadly that isn't the case.
While the garbage is
tightly packed underground,
it remains in an oxygen list environment
there it creates methane gas,
a huge contributor to global warming.
Landfills are the third largest
producers of methane gas on the world.
And as the planets
landfills continue to fill,
they have the potential to eclipse farming
and fossil fuel production and become
the highest producers
with our landfills full.
Where would the rest of our garbage go?
Well, we wouldn't bless it up into space.
That's far too expensive.
Instead,
we'd most likely burn it a practice that
some European countries are currently
doing. However, if
every landfill did this,
it would create even more
potentially deadly pollution
making the air we breathe.
Toxic recycling prevents
almost 200 million metric
tons of greenhouse gases from
polluting our environment each year.
That's the equivalent of the fumes
produced by over 39 million cars on the
highway.
A lot of our trash would end up in places
where it's not supposed to go like the
ocean.
Right now,
the world's oceans are home to millions
of floating pieces of plastic with no
one recycling.
Even more of this debris would end up in
the water killing millions of fish and
making the water and swimmable, but
these might be the least of our worries,
at least in the short term.
What we would start to notice quickly
would be our natural resources being
destroyed. You see, recycling isn't just
about keeping trash out of landfills.
It also helps us sustain our
natural resources like timber.
It's estimated nearly 7 billion trees
are cut down globally each year.
In 2017 the United States recycled
over 68 million tons of paper.
Without this,
more trees would have to be cut down to
sustain the paper supply leading to an
even higher amount of
deforestation than we have today.
You can say goodbye to fossil fuels.
In addition to making our cars go,
they're the source of
all our plastic products.
Fossil fuels are currently expected to
deplete by 2050 but without recycling,
fossil fuel consumption would be higher
than ever leading to the precious
resource being gone much sooner.
So with no one recycling,
the world would have no choice
but to change. For instance,
new water bottles being researched
today are being made out of biopolymer,
a material that's composed of bacteria.
These bottles are designed to
biodegrade in just 18 months.
That would help a lot as the world is
currently using over a million plastic
water bottles per minute.
Other materials and products would
eventually have to follow suit.
Maybe one day we'll live in a world
where everything is biodegradable,
even electronics, but that's
a story for another. What if.